while teslas and the like make for good
headlines the reality is that even if
every car on the roads today went
electric it wouldn't be enough to curb
global emissions to avoid catastrophic
climate change
greenhouse gas emissions from
transportation account for about 29 of
total u.s greenhouse gas emissions so
what about the other 71
buildings across america burn fossil
fuels to operate what we want to do is
make that all electric instead of
burning oil and gas to give us the
energy and electricity we need we want
to do a hundred percent clean energy all
electric we want to turn buildings into
teslas just like a tesla or an electric
vehicle is all electric with no fossil
fuels we want to do that with our
buildings and if we can do it in one
building we can do it in all buildings
and if we do it in all buildings we'll
reduce 30 of us greenhouse gas emissions
if such a reduction in emissions from
buildings everywhere became a reality in
the near future the planet could
potentially avoid the worst consequences
of global warming
donnell baird is the ceo and founder of
block power whose mission is to help
america's building infrastructure go
green we're a climate tech startup that
turns buildings into teslas we rip out
the fossil fuel equipment heating
cooling hot water equipment we replace
it with all electric equipment that
makes buildings greener healthier and
smarter all across america we want every
american to have a free data-driven
clean energy recommendation for their
building or their church or their school
or their synagogue so that's the first
part the second part is we got to help
them raise the trillions of dollars that
are going to be required to pay green
construction firms to install clean
energy equipment in every home and every
building in america we've been working
with goldman sachs and microsoft to
develop a new financial product that
allows us to finance or lease clean
energy to all americans including the
lowest income americans
i started thinking about block power
really i was 22 23 years old i was a
community organizer i was trained by the
same community organizing group that had
trained barack obama and i was walking
around brooklyn one freezing winter day
it must have been like 21 degrees
fahrenheit and i looked around and all
of the apartment buildings had their
windows open you could see the steam and
the heat like pouring out of the windows
because the giant apartment buildings
and complexes were being overheated and
it reminded me of when i was a kid we
had to have our windows open in our
apartment during the winter on very cold
days because we did not have heat in our
building so we had to turn on the oven
open up the oven door and then we had to
open up a window to release carbon
monoxide
in 2019 new york city passed the climate
mobilization act a commitment to right
their wrongs
nearly 70 percent of new york's carbon
emissions are from their buildings and
the city aims by 2030 to cut their
pollution by 40 percent building owners
who don't meet the reduction
requirements will be faced with fines a
penalty of
268 dollars per every assessed ton of
carbon over the limit
what we're doing is trying to modernize
energy efficiency in green buildings by
building it right from day one with
software with mobile computing cloud
computing statistical analysis machine
learning using the internet of things
and low cost sensors
block power purchases clean energy
equipment we hire green construction
firms and we project manage them to
install green energy equipment in every
building and every home when a building
owner first is interested in working
with block power we have them fill out a
10-minute quiz or survey about how the
energy equipment in their building
currently works our software system
collects the data from the form we start
to run an analysis of what kinds of
clean energy recommendations make sense
for that building the building owner
gets a report from us that tells them
what kinds of
mix of clean energy equipment makes
sense for their building while building
owners may save money in the long run
the upfront investment in energy
efficiency can be insurmountable for
some based on data from the department
of energy the national average energy
burden for low-income households is
three times higher than for other
households one of the main reasons is
that low-income homes are more
frequently burdened with outdated
equipment and other poor housing
conditions that can lead to higher than
average energy use and costs groundswell
a non-profit renewable energy advocacy
group noted in an analysis that the
bottom twenty percent of earners spent
almost ten percent of their income on
electricity that's more than seven times
the portion of income that the top
twenty percent pays most americans don't
have you know twenty thousand fifty
thousand a hundred thousand dollars
laying around to convert your building
to make it all electric but if we can
stretch those payments out over time and
make sure that the monthly payment is
lower than what you're currently paying
for oil or for gas then that's an
attractive option for saving money and
saving the planet this model is already
being implemented in new york maryland
colorado and other states with incentive
programs for solar panels whereby low
interest loans allow homeowners to make
monthly payments that are comparable and
often less than typical electric bills
i think to date we've raised around 100
million dollars we have been really
fortunate to have some world-class
investors salesforce is an investor
goldman sachs the american family life
insurance corporation but there's four
trillion dollars of projects to do i
mean there's four trillion dollars worth
of buildings to decarbonize across
america
i think the most important thing that
we're doing is recently we were selected
by the city of ithaca to decarbonize the
entire city meaning every building no
fossil fuels we have an eight-year
timeline by which we have to decarbonize
the entire city so it's the first city
in america in the first city in the
world to fully decarbonize
we know that we have eight or nine years
to make massive interventions in the way
that we operate and the way that our
economy works in order to avoid the
worst impacts of climate change and if
we can decarbonize all cities across
america then 30
of our greenhouse gas emissions will be
avoided and that means america will have
led the world
away from the worst consequences of
climate change and so we're feeling the
pressure but we're really excited to try
and step up to the challenge